說實在如果要看臺灣的供應鏈的訂單狀況等等的
這都是落後指標了
以現在來講其實都是
因為這已經是一層一層就是一定要算力需求很好
然後CSP才會繼續投資
那他們才會來這邊加單買這個東西
所以他們真的看到不好
到他們開始砍單
這中間可能隔了三個月到半年
所以你等到聽到臺灣公司說訂單被砍的時候
你現在搞不好已經跌三個月到半年了
AI時代來臨
投資也能充滿智慧
富邦AI Pro專業分析資料
透視趨勢
輕鬆一點掌握全球市場脈動
有AI 投資更Pro
現在就點擊知識欄
趕快去下載
歡迎收看富邦證券YouTube頻道
我是Sabrina
經過前兩集的討論
相信大家對於AI商業化進程
和產業發展有了更完整的認識
不過隨著AI相關產業
歷經一波快速成長
市場也開始關注未來資金流向
以及高檔震盪的風險
今天我們就邀請騰訊投資的投資長
陳振華 建掌
帶大家一起來分析
建掌好
哈囉主持人好
各位觀眾朋友大家好
首先想請教建掌
您如何來看待
2026年下半年全球股市
市場最大的變化是什麼呢
應該這樣講
先討論崩盤的原因嘛
那崩盤的原因其實第一個是
本來籌碼就很亂
那其實如果看
不管是一般我們看什麼
貪婪恐慌指數啊
牛熊指標啊
或是融資育兒啊
那這些呢可以觀察指標
你會發現籌碼就是很亂
那籌碼亂不代表一定會跌
它只是代表你的震盪會比較激烈
那通常股價漲點我們是看景氣有沒有優於預期或是不如預期
那其實六七月份以來其實景氣是有一點不如預期的
那不如預期的話包括幾個
第一個是在六月底七月初的時候
市場在傳就是Entropic的ARR成長率不如預期
那就剛講它之前成長飛快
但是六七月稍微有一點漸緩的一個趨勢
就到了五六月之後就有可能是卡算力不足或等等各種原因
那它的成長率稍微有一點趨緩
那當然如果你要討論到全球股市的話
我覺得另外幾個都是比較重金的因素
這就比較不好說
第一個當然是打仗
那到底伊朗戰爭要拖到什麼時候
要打不打
我們只知道川普不是在tackle
就是在tackle的路上
但是三不五時就會嚇你一下
這個是免不了的事情
那第二個就是因為這樣子
所以導致最近看到
美國十年期公債殖利率也飆得蠻高的
那當然進一步的往上走
那我相信對股市會有很大的壓力
前兩年我們也看過
就是債券莫名其妙跌了一個月之後
股市一定會被拖累的
這是連動的
所以債市如果一直低迷的話
這個對我們也會有一些concern
大概會需要注意
所以總金面的話
當然還是有一些這種疑慮要
要考量進來啦
但基本面我們剛講的就是看算力需求
有沒有開始繼續回溫的一個現象
AI產業進入了高檔震盪期
您認為市場資金
債富可能聚焦哪一些AI產業的環節
其實都沒有太大變化
就是對我們來講
一定都是整個供應鏈裡面相對來說
就不管是新的技術或者是一些新的材料
就剛剛講的一定就是說看
我們一定會看NVIDIA它的產品roadmap
那它的產品的這個技術藍圖裡面
它接下來規劃產品它大概是哪些是新的東西
那然後哪些是新的零件原料
它的用量會增加最多
那比如說前一陣子我們最常講的就是CPU
就是光的部分
那很明顯的它在Rubin Ultra
就是2027年下半年這個產品
他就會開始大量的用CPU的這個架構
那用了這個架構
所以相對來講對光的這個供應鏈
大家的預期就會比較高
當然市場之前預期很高
所以國家漲上去也跌得很兇
因為籌碼很亂
那但是之所以會漲到那種
本夢比很誇張的地步
就是因為可以看到這是未來
可能以技術藍圖上面
看起來成長最明顯的一塊
大概是這樣子
所以針對
其實說穿了還是固定了幾個東西
就是這個光通訊
或者是一些高速傳輸的一些材料
不管是PCB版等等的一些東西
或者是其他
當然可能就是Compatibility去看一下
就比如說不管是這個Memory
記憶體或者是其他的一些相關的一些
這種我們叫的Compatibility這種原物料
是不是有哪些隨著這個產品的演進
它的用量會開始比較會更多
然後會有精確的一個現象
大概是這樣子
這兩年市場關注的焦點
幾乎都集中在AI的硬體供應鏈
那未來是不是有可能逐漸的轉向
AI的應用端
那有哪一些的產業最有機會收回
轉到AI應用端這個一定會
那只是說對臺灣這邊來講比較麻煩
是我們只有硬體
所以就有點像當年
比如說我們在研究PC硬體
研究Smartphone的硬體
那就在玩臺灣的股票
但是整道硬體
比如說到了一個界限之後
大家就在開始玩互聯網
比如說就開始玩美國的Facebook
然後開始玩Google Microsoft
玩所謂SaaS的行業
然後中國就是玩幾個互聯網巨頭
那接下來一定也往這邊走
硬體發展到某個階段就會往軟體走
那往軟體走這邊很
不幸的這個比較不是臺灣的強項
所以到時候可能會看美股
就會比較多一些這方面的機會
那當然這裡面第一個一定是CSP
因為CSP剛剛講的不管Google
這個Microsoft
他們其實這幾年投資這麼多
投資這麼積極
投到現金流都要變成負的
理由就是因為他們知道這個未來帶來的現金流
跟未來的獲利很可觀
所以這兩三年投完之後
這個折舊結束
他們以後的現金流的
那個進來的幅度會非常驚人
所以AI的算力需求
如果維持在一定的水準
並沒有忽然掉下來的話
CSP他們的獲利
以後一定會顯著的提升
那以前他們就是巨頭了
以後是更大的巨頭
所以這幾個公司都會是
CSP這一塊一定是蠻值得看的
這是一個角度
那以及就是
幫客人去用這些模型的公司
一些agent
那這些相關的公司
是不是有一些投資機會
這可能就再進一步再看
目前都小公司
比如說像我們剛剛提到的OpenRouter
那它其實最近就是也有一輪募資啊等等
它的市值也增加不少之類的
就是說當然它現在它就是一個更小的公司
但是它在這上面也有一些相關的生意可以做
那也是靠著AI起來的一家公司
那這上面也會是之後可能可以關注的一些投資機會
只是剛剛提到的這類型的公司在臺灣比較少
所以就是還是看美股這樣子
美股或是鹿港股可能會比較多一點
那對於一般投資人來說
要如何觀察市場的變化呢
那面對下半年市場的波動
投資人可以從哪些的角度來觀察
AI產業和相關企業的基本面
剛剛講的是硬體投資告一個段落
然後開始已經結束了
要到軟體的這一段
那硬體投資什麼時候告一個段落
現在看起來都還不知道
明年一定還是一個資本支出
成長很高的一年
那現在你說2028年之後
會不會有很大變數
這個可能有
但明年因為股市一定領先一年看
今年可以狂還是因為覺得明年不錯
明年還能不能狂還就要看後年能不能不錯
對那剛剛講的明年資本支出
如果進一步的從今年的
四五大CSV今天是8000億
明年大概是1.2 1.4兆
那後年還能夠增加多少
它能夠變2兆
這個是另外一個要考慮的問題
那以及就是說
現在不是他們能不能花錢的問題
因為他們現金流也會越來越強
他們就算願意花錢
到時候的問題是
有沒有那麼多的電
有沒有那麼多的地
我們剛剛講到
然後其實現在美國在蓋Data Center
已經遇到很多瓶頸了
很多地方的抗爭
他們光是連現在
剛剛講的8000億資本之初
蓋了這麼多Data Center
就有很多在Delay
然後或者是被Cancel掉
那可能要另外找地方來弄
環評做比較久
我如果未來一年要蓋兩倍以上的產能
那我哪裡找到這些地方
那抗爭可能會更嚴重
那會不會蓋不出來
所以到最後你還要考慮到
客觀環境面的一個問題
導致會不會是明年
就是最後資本指數的高峰
後年上不去了
因為你也沒有這麼多的基礎設施
可以趕上你的腳步
那這些都是需要考慮的地方
所以
對我們來說
就是明年的確有可能是硬體
的最後好的一年
當然不是說後來會掉下來
只是說後年成長率可能就會趨緩
因為沒有那麼多地可以找
或那麼多店可以提供
大概是這個樣子
有哪些的關鍵訊號是值得需要留意的呢
關鍵訊號
就剛剛提到說
你要觀察到最底端的算力需求
其實就是你要去追OpenRouter的資料
那OpenRouter也是公開網站
大家都可以上去看
那你要怎麼整理這些資料
這個大家都看得到
那剛剛講它有一定的參考性
但不是唯一的指標
那再來就是類似就是GPU的價格
就是目前GPU租賃價格到底是怎麼樣
那當然Bloomberg上面有
那你沒有訂閱Bloomberg
那一些網絡
說實在自己去Amazon上面註冊
然後說你要去租
那你也可以看到它各個地方
美國各個Data Center的報價
所以是都不一樣
每天都可以看
就是自己去註冊一個賬號
自己去追蹤
所以當然要很花時間
所以實際上要
真的一般投資人要很認真的研究到
最底層的AI需求的變化
那這些指標都是可以自己去follow up
只是要花時間 要去整理
那其他的
說實在如果要看臺灣的供應鏈的
訂單狀況等等的
這都是落後指標了
以現在來講其實都是
因為這已經是一層一層
就是一定要算力需求很好
然後CSP才會繼續投資
那他們才會來這邊加單買這個東西
那所以他們真的看到不好
到他們開始砍單
這中間可能隔了三個月到半年
所以你等到聽到臺灣公司說
訂單被砍的時候
股價搞不好已經跌三個月到半年了
所以我們還想請建長來幫我們展望未來
除了AI之外
未來三到五年
有哪一些的新趨勢是值得關注的
或是有哪一些的產業
有機會成為下一波的市場焦點呢
應該說以這個Jensen之前在講的
我們現在是今年起來就是靠Agentic AI
就代理型的AI
那往後看其實一定是另外幾個
一個是AGAI的部分
那一個是我們叫Physical AI的部分
那AGAI當然就是看你的這個AI應用
能不能夠普及到所有人的每個產品
不管是手機或是電腦
那當然AGAI理論上是有機會
看起來越做越好了
但現在卡一個瓶頸是記憶體太貴
所以當你要跑AGAI
你的手機也好PC也好
你的記憶體的容量就不能太小
偏偏記憶體這兩年又長得非常誇張
所以你要看到消費性電子的復甦
其實不太容易
因為記憶體就卡住了很多地方
所以可能要等到過一兩年
記憶體價格變回比較合理的階段的時候
再看看AGI有沒有機會起來
另外一個剛剛講的Physical AI
其實一般就是在講機器人
或是在講自駕車
類似這類型的一個應用
目前的技術還沒有很成熟
但是剛剛講到三五年的角度
三五年我相信機器人
應該會變成一個蠻成熟的一個產品
那不敢說是已經跟電影裡面一樣
那麼的栩栩如生
然後完全懂
但是我覺得佛羅很多
簡單的應用應該說
可以不管是工廠的一些幫忙
或是一些家庭的一些
簡單的一些掃地的這種
簡單的一些應用
我相信這種人形機器人的
大概三五年的時間給它
它應該會變成一個還算成熟的產品
那它身上用到的半導體零件
感測器或者一些機構元件
也是一個非常
產資也是會是一個很大的行業
所以我覺得這也是另外一個
值得期待的地方
再次感謝建掌的精彩分享
如果喜歡今天的內容
也歡迎幫我們按贊訂閱
並開啟小鈴鐺
鎖定富邦振政的頻道
才不會錯過最新的市場觀點
和投資趨勢分析哦
我們下次見
拜拜